foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we are back fellas we back like we
never left it was here last week you all
know what we did last week we came up
with the parlay that actually hit and so
we are back again what up everybody my
name is Greg Ivory next to me is the man
MB I like the call of MB he's known as
Michael Bolin
and next to him is the man that connects
us to you guys producer Ryan what's up
fellas how we feeling today
feeling good man feeling good pretty
exciting day
I feel like the sports books are
vulnerable tonight so maybe we'll take
some more money from FanDuel let's go
let's take some more how you doing
producer Ryan how you feeling over there
and we're gonna hit two parlays in a row
on this show that's how I feel I mean
like this is this is amazing box we're
we're so hot right now like you you
really can't cool us down
all right well Ryan's ready mb's ready
I'm ready last week
we all built our five leg parlay and it
hit so we gotta run it back drop your
Best Bets for tonight in the chat and
we'll cook them into a parlay Ryan what
does the chat like tonight what are they
talking about all right Matt Rocio who
jumped in here before we started and
said that he cashed USA uh Iran one
nothing correct score so the man's hot
uh he jumped in and said hoping we can
collectively pull off some heat tonight
I'm big on Dallas and for a prop I'm not
big huge in all caps on Clay over 17 and
a half points
so we already got we already got some
plays in this chat going
already got some cookies in the chat
going he said clay clay over point total
over 17 and a half yes sir I like it I
like it Clay's been balling I don't know
if you guys watched he's been bawling no
bias Bolin I know that's right oh
goodness
for the people that may not have been
here last week or any time before Greg
is the biggest Warriors fan I know so
any Warriors bet is probably going to go
down on the like side for him no wise no
bias but Clay's been bawling I don't
like my he's just been balling these
last recent games when man plays with
ball and I'll give you some numbers if
you want Michael Bolin I'll send you
some clay I'll give you some Klay
Thompson numbers if you want Ryan you're
in the chat you're you're you're surfing
while I give Michael Ballin these Klay
Thompson numbers he went for 21 last
game the game before that he went for
20. the game before that he went for 18
and then the game before that he went
for 41 and the game before that he went
for 20 then 19 team like I could keep
going and be there's a reason why I like
it it ain't just because it's the word
it's the reason why I like it all right
well well let's say let's see Matt Rocio
who gave us the pick it's his first time
in the Stream should we plug it in did
we got the first leg
oh we have some other plays in here but
I'll read those as a second leg I think
we can confidently say we all like clay
over 17 and a half points correct
yes sir I like it add it add it to the
card all right shall we keep going
hey yeah let's keep going I'm seeing a
lot of Reggie Bullock in the comments
[Music]
this we're not what are we doing let's
we're trying to win Greg we're not no
Reggie unless we're taking unders
hey we are trying to win we we we we
we've been talking about this we are
trying to win uh somebody says see
Thomas says Luca four plus threes like
come on like
are we serious about that one he's like
Steph Curry but listen he has done it
before but if we're trying to win and be
confident in these picks four threes is
probably too many that's just my
thoughts so I'm a girl I see an
interesting one I see a very interesting
one J Millie says pull over three and a
half assist
Jordan pool over three and a half
assists we know that he runs that second
lineup for the Warriors
do we see that uh
listen I I love Jordan Poole he's a
Michigan guy so he's very high up in my
book
um I only worry that since he does run
that second unit if there's a lead
involved and they're trying to play from
behind could be a little iffy it doesn't
seem like that many though so maybe
we'll hold on to that one because it's
not a bad play
let me list off some of his numbers in
this last Jordan pool like he runs the
second unit
he is the point guard in that second
unit although he scores he I think he
averages a 16 16 a game he is the
facilitator in that lineup just listen
off some of his numbers last game six
assists game before that six assists
game before that five assists game
before that four assists four eight like
my man he he he's gonna pass the ball
Greg Greg May I interrupt your
propaganda for a second go ahead we have
other plays that we can get to or not we
don't have to just play the the Warriors
second line Angel Sito Luca 30 plus
points C Thomas has been relentlessly
dropping Curry over six and a half
assists how about this because I feel
like we have already taken the minus
115. if this is gonna be five legs we
need to tease some things down so
we could take Luca 30 plus points I
believe is point total currently is 32
and a half or we could take Curry shall
we say six plus assists
which one do you guys feel more
confident in
Jordan pool over three and a half
assists
I don't know why we stopped talking
about that
hey I think I'm with Greg I think that
if we are going to put it plus
I literally don't know why we stopped
talking about that when we were sitting
here talking about it we went through
the numbers the numbers make sense the
audience voted for it plug it in what
are we talking about three and a half
I'm gonna agree simply because that
second unit is such a spark plug for the
Warriors that he doesn't really have to
do much right he's just passing the ball
to the corner for threes I think this is
going to be a really close game both of
these teams play each other pretty hard
so I don't know if there's going to be
that big a leads he's going to be in a
position to get three to five to six and
then who knows so once all we need is
four I kind of like it
cool this is for producer Max in the
chat in the chat I see Jay Milly says
pulled over the chat wants it if you
guys want the Jordan pool look at Lee
Porter pool assist over three and a half
RJ shaft five I'm with Greg 100 on the
pool assist I mean how much more chat do
we need how much more chat do we need
lock it in
it took a while it took a while yeah
you guys are going to kill me with these
parlays
if we keep listen this is all I'm gonna
say if we keep taking plus 100 legs this
five leg parlay is gonna be 35 to one
which I don't hate but again we're
trying to win
I never thought I'd be the one to talk
us down on Lower odds ever
I see an interesting one here Josh Hart
plus over seven and a half points
okay
he's okay now you talking MB he's he's
been scoring he's been scoring at a
decent clip I know he's had some up and
down games but that looks like a low
number to me and that team has been
playing way above their skis I think so
I think it's worth considering let's see
what it does when we uh when we look at
it oh somebody
yeah that's that's too juicy now yeah
maybe that was the play this morning
yeah yeah maybe that was the play this
morning we can't go any lower than that
yeah
uh what else we got in here yeah
Mark Perkins says Brunson assists hit us
with the numbers so we can tap these in
uh Wiggins Wiggins hold on Al Mendoza
he's a faithful he is a faithful he
always is this is just a warrior Frank
we gotta if the Warriors have a bad game
this parlay is dead
yeah
I'm just playing with you Greg I'm
playing with you I'm done I'm done
I'm done I'm I'm completely done I'm not
saying anything else for this parlay
this is in you guys's hands since you
guys don't want to follow the people the
people are giving these pigs
we're just it's just cherry picking
we're cherry picking the comments I see
one Jaden Joyner Julius Randle 20 plus
points it's his birthday
love a birthday narrative a birthday
maybe maybe that's like my personality
trait but if you have a narrative and
it's your birthday I'm so in on this so
let's see what the number is minus 130.
I like that I like that honestly all
right Julius randle's been playing well
and and the truth about it whoa this is
gonna be a big
we need to take it easy on these next
two legs as you can see we're already up
to plus 524 and I think last week's was
what plus 600 or something like that
like plus 631
okay hey guys all right I said I was
done but like I can't be done because
we're live right now but I just want to
let you guys know that the commenters I
didn't say this the commenter said
Andrew Wiggins 15 plus points that's
what they said they said that I didn't
say it I think
they said that they said it Justin
Clinton also said Steph Curry under 30
points how do we how do we feel about
that
only positive Warriors vibes
[Laughter]
see he's he's doing his thing again
where he's he's done he doesn't want to
talk no more
all right uh we have M Clyde 2 saying he
likes the Josh Hart pick though so we
just need for the reference we weren't
be we weren't able to lock it in because
it was my or plus seven and a half over
seven and a half points the original
number is ten and a half so we cannot
get that low no uh I see Obi topping two
plus three is from J Jeff
uh
uh let's go back
we can also
somebody here says CT Thomas let's do a
nice little Terence Man 10 plus points
let's take a look at that all right so
for the clips
never bet on Wiggins and Clay over 13.
those are bad vibes
bad vibes minus 390.
now now we're talking about for sure
legs here
yeah yeah what's that what's that minus
three let's see what it does let's see
what it does let's see what it does it
says 684. I don't know I saw that tint
yeah let's add that let's let's go big
all right yeah I like it all right now
it's gonna give us a chance to get
crazy if we want to also I want to make
sure we go back
as we're looking for more plays last
week we definitely got the the Patrick
Beverly under six points yeah and we
swerved it shout out to Hoppy he
messaged
and was like Hey this was the goose egg
play of the year so too bad we don't
have Patrick Beverly on the on the on
the Slate side shout out to Hoppy hey
shout out to Hoppy because that hit that
was super long you guys I was telling
you guys about it but then you know Ryan
said it wasn't juicy and this in the
chat and then you know we didn't embed
it but we got we got enough juice now I
will say this uh
King J one two seven says uh Jalen
Brunson over one and a half threes
we're staring at it it's minus 140.
Jalen Brunson has been at least one that
makes fans wanted
can we go one three
let's we can go on three and what's the
odds plus 782 I don't hate that wow I
don't hate that at all oh my God yeah
we've done enough of the legwork on the
other legs hey
walk us over and then hey everybody in
the chat if you guys like it we need
thumbs up if you guys don't like it give
put a thumbs down but put what you don't
like about the parlay Ryan I think we
need a little recap yes real quick can
we see what it looks like what it would
look like with over one and a half yeah
it's a lot no no I know I've impressed
it I know I know
now I'm too tempted okay so yeah we're
walking over here uh we started out Klay
Thompson over 17 and a half points uh
that's first leg second leg Greg's
propaganda Jordan pool over three and a
half assists I think he I think he got
in his burner in the in the chat and
dropped that pick uh Third Leg Julius
Randle on his birthday to score at least
20 points 20 plus points uh and then
we've got our fourth leg was Terence
Mann 10 plus points minus 390 for the
Clippers and then last like Jalen
Brunson just one three that's all we
asked just one three
I'm seeing a lot of positive vibes in
the chat fellas go in and look in there
King Jay saying I like it
we got CT Thomas I like lamax and
Jackson thumbs up we got Matt Matt Rocio
five thumbs up man
everybody loves it I think we might be
in here hey and look oh Darius Cofield
says Jordan pool assist thumbs down oh
that's all right well now we're getting
now we're getting the actual feedback
because red Mac 23 says man thumbs down
I'm willing to I'm willing to move a
little bit on on Terence man maybe maybe
a Christian would play
okay let's take a look we don't have to
call it just yet I do like that the the
chat has given us immediate feedback
yeah it's important we got man's gonna
sell but other than that thumbs up so
looks like man's the only leg that's
really in question
everybody's saying Clay is shaky we got
a lot of people saying they like it a
lot of people saying uh thumbs up or a
lot of people giving a thumbs up few
thumbs down but I see more thumbs UPS
than thumbs down I see wait okay and
thumbs down I see a I see a fun one here
carvon Everett zubots eight rebounds I'm
sure his rebounds have to be way over
eight so
didn't he have like 20 26
and like 20 something rebounds not too
long ago so
this might bring us value-wise it might
bring us down a little bit but how many
people are in a good spot eight
okay so say we all right are we are we
in agreement that we would take out the
Terence man
like yeah let's let's swap that one and
see what it does all right
let's get him out of here and then that
still set guys still seven to one that's
so good I like that swap a lot
is a vacuum down there just swallowing
up rebounds so I think this is a better
play and we cover in that same game
anyway so got some action in all of them
I
I really like this
I kind of don't see how this doesn't hit
I was avoiding I was hoping to say that
you said it last time so
that's a good point yeah yeah all right
there's no way it loses then now we are
somebody somebody says zubach is is
shaky because of nerk
so there's
I don't wanna yeah all right no bad Bobs
goodbye
we don't read the negative comments we
cherry pick
a lot of gvos yeah
I think that's what it is Ryan one more
time for the people we're going to rock
with it or we need before
thumbs up thumbs up last time thumbs up
in the in the comments if you guys are
rocking with it thumbs down if you're
not Ryan let's recap it because I feel
like this is what we're gonna rock with
but uh I'll just give the people more
time to fill up the chat all right Clay
Thompson over 17 and a half points
Jordan Poole over three and a half
assists
joyous Randall 20 plus points Jalen
Brunson one plus three and then our last
leg which was zubach
eight plus rebounds
I love it I like it we're getting we're
getting we're getting good feedback from
the chat I see a couple uh thumbs up
see people saying you guys took out uh
you guys swapped Zoo back that was
genius
um they are geniuses I've been hearing
that I've been hearing a lot of people
think that we're geniuses
somebody sponges spicy sponge says
there's a lot so therefore I mean we're
locking it in can we have a Russian real
quick just uh Around the Horn very very
quickly what leg are we most nervous
about if we could just have an honest
second
I think personally
I'm not really worried about it
I'm just gonna be very honest we have
Julius Randle on his birthday he's going
to show out we have Clay who's been
hotter than the sun right now Jordan
Poole covering that number the last five
or six games as Greg so eloquently
alluded to yeah we went less for for
Brunson all he's got to do is make one
three and we went less for zubots who
gets probably nine to ten boards a game
I don't know why I would be worried the
only thing I'm worried about is Julius
Randle to be completely honest it's just
putting money in on the New York Knicks
is always it's his birthday it's his
birthday we we go we go turn up I'm
getting feedback I'm getting feedback
I'm sorry guys we're gonna move on but
I'm getting feedback about the Jordan
pool play
okay good or bad
bad
they're saying that they want to switch
Christian with Jordan pool
yeah what
I see I saw Christian Wood 20 plus do I
like that I don't know he's 18 and a
half this is point total what if what if
we did 15 for him
the Jordan pool play was yeah of course
the plus money right it was plus money
it was plus money that's going to take
us down a little bit but we'll see how
much uh all right let's take a look at
it
20. even though I do I do think Jordan
Jordan pool is is gonna um
have a great game oh guys we're not
doing this okay all right that's gonna
be a no from me
we gotta stick to our guns what were we
talking about Greg we were talking about
college
when you're taking the test in college
you go with your gut yeah we're all
sitting here because we went with our
gut you came in with conviction you
showed us the numbers I like that you're
telling us now
that the pool play is not a lock you're
too late we got our like got the vibe
straight let's go did you guys I like
that Scantron discussion is that what
happened
uh no we were just talking about how we
would love to go back to college oh okay
yeah agreed yeah I didn't that's I
didn't do any betting in college by the
way nobody come ask me any questions
great times at College all right Ryan
let's go over those odds one more final
time before we move on okay hammering at
home where we've locked in on the thumbs
up uh Klay Thompson over 17 and a half
points short and pull over three and a
half assists Julius Randle 20 plus
points Jalen Brunson one plus made three
and Zubat eight plus rebounds I think
this is gonna win there it is I think
it's gonna win I believe that we will
win I believe
all right here we go let's move on we're
seven weeks into the NBA season guys
we're seven weeks so let's talk Futures
let's pull up FanDuel everybody in the
chat let us know who your favorite
future bet is Ryan MB and B I'll start
with you bro
who are you looking at on that Futures
list and like
I think I want to put a bet on them to
win the NBA championship
all right for the record I did not do
this because I'm talking to Mr Warriors
but you got Steph Curry at ten to one to
win the MVP
now hear me out the Warriors started a
little slow they're playing better I
like what he's doing he's doing what
everybody knows he can do
ten to one to me feels like really good
value at this moment because the two
guys that are in front of him are
Giannis and Luca and they're playing out
of their minds right now if they regress
at all he's going to move up in those
odds and you'll get what we love to call
closing line value so ten to one for me
feels like a good number for Steph
there it is my man's Rocco with Steph
Curry to win MVP
I like that one bowling you know me I'm
an I mean I'm a Warriors fan uh but the
thing about Steph the thing about Steph
I I want your bet to win I hope he does
win MVP because that'll be great great
things for the Golden State Warriors but
think about Steph is he always starts
off hot and then those legs catch up to
him in January February and then my guys
you know playing with injuries and later
in the season and then the Warriors just
go win championships so uh MVP
maybe I like it I do like it but maybe
Ryan talk to me about the people in the
chat what are they saying do you see any
interesting future bets from them
uh yeah I see Naz J Ron sang in all caps
the Celtics go back to the finals uh I
disagree I I agree I'm sorry I agree
pretty heavily whoa no I know there's no
bias involved nobody you just have a
stroke
I'm not going back no they're going back
they're they're they're winning it all
they may never lose another game based
on the way that they're playing right
now uh Al Mendoza uh disagreeing with
bowling a little bit uh saying Luca MVP
Luca MVP has kind of been a popular take
in this chat
uh for a few weeks now uh do you guys
like Giannis is clearly on another level
from everybody but do you think that you
know the NBA might switch it up a little
bit and be like we need to give the
award to somebody else voter fatigue is
what they call it
no maybe I don't know I just yeah I
don't think so I don't think so but that
might happen you know that might happen
but
the way he's I mean I
I've hated the argument that like LeBron
could win MVP every year like you just
give it to it you know let it be
objective so I don't know and one of the
objective comments I see in here is Shaw
gilges Alexander should be an MVP
discussion that is very interesting
definitely on the most improved radar
definitely should be on that mvp radar
he's averaging over 30 a game with the
Thunder my God like what more could you
do and you're talking in terms of Most
Valuable Player
if they don't have that 30 a game they
probably don't even win a game this year
he has 55-1 to win MVP so maybe maybe
there's a Sprinkle situation there
who knows yeah you could put a slick 50
on that yeah you just hope uh chef chef
Peezy uh Benedict matheran Sixth Man of
the Year and rookie of the year uh if
that's not a Pacers fan I don't know I
don't know what is he's winning one not
not both
and yeah he said and
uh let's see demigod uh embiid has a
great chance to win MVP but only if he
stays healthy you're never gonna get me
to say anything positive about
Philadelphia so I'm gonna I'm gonna stay
out of this one what do you guys think
about that take
hey indeed has been balling been balling
but I feel like he's a it's the same
thing with Steph Curry is he going to be
healthy because with the MVP race you
have to also play the durability game
you you have to play the durability game
is that person gonna be healthy at the
end of the year Giannis is a great bet
because Giannis is a freak he's a freak
athlete
be honestly he might be there you know
the the odds are that he might be there
at the end of the year plan for that uh
Milwaukee team uh so I don't know I
don't know about him B I watched him a
year ago and uh bowling I've never seen
nobody fall on the ground more than Joel
and beat the man it literally falls on
the ground for for for no reason so I
don't know I don't know about that one
yeah go ahead sorry bowling no I was
gonna say embiid is a lot comes with him
when he's playing the game uh it's a lot
of theatrics a lot of social media posts
so if they could get back up to the top
of the East he should be in the
discussion because he's that damn good
but I'm with you I don't know I can't I
can't trust the the health concerns
because he's never really healthy out
for a full season
right yeah I think that's a that's a
fair take I mean he does he does get
injured a lot so that plays it a part in
it and he's 12-1 like when he's playing
when he's on the court he's playing
incredible but he had 12-1 odds you have
to factor in the health uh Gucci says
Jaden Ivey Rookie of the Year and Jason
Tatum MVP
wow I think I expected a little more out
of Jaden Ivy to start but maybe that's
because he was one of the best players
in the Big Ten last year he's just a
freak athlete man he's a great talent
gets downhill can make shots can't
facilitate
but it's going to be hard to win the
Rookie of the Year when your team's 5
and 17. you know like you just got to
play a little better if the Pistons can
find their stride I definitely like it
because I think a lot of people had
higher hopes for the Pistons and that
narrative has kind of shifted because
they started really really slow
but I like
Jason Tatum that might be a good
sprinkle we just talked about durability
what are those guys that'll be there uh
with that Celtics team throughout this
season so uh
sprinkle I like that I like the tasted
potatoes I don't know Jason Tatum's plus
350. I think I'm whipping out the tool
kit and I'm grabbing my hammer I don't I
don't know if I'm I don't know if I'm
taking the sprinkle wait a second fella
fellas I see Hollywood and DC says
Devin Booker MVP
we gotta talk about this man I I don't
know about that play that's interesting
take Greg what do you think
y'all know about that one bro
yeah I'm not even going to waste a lot
of time on that when I'm not betting
that one I'll tell you that right now
that's a donation
that was the donation
donate two more let's get two more guys
and then let's let's let's let's keep
this thing going we're gonna get on up
out of here actually let's get two marks
all right yeah we got Leal jumping in
here saying F the Futures I need money
now you got a place but Futures is like
the stock market you got to invest right
hey I feel them no yeah it is like the
stock market if you if you play a good
future early you will reap the benefits
when you win that future so don't forget
about that don't forget about that the
investment part of the future but I Ryan
MB I feel Em I'm trying to win today I'm
trying to win now and that's why we did
that parlay so uh that's true that's
true it's also just like a good way it's
like when your teams suck like mine you
know it gives you another reason to root
for another team you know
like your season's over in week three
and it's like all right I'll root for
somebody else uh MJ 777 Tyrese
Halliburton most improved
love it it's been balling yeah
absolutely love it when you talk about
how important the point guard position
is in this league even though the Pacers
aren't really one of that those better
teams or teams we're gonna think are
going to be there at the end 40 assists
and no turnovers in his last few games
that's absurd I mean you could get a
turnover for dribbling off your leg he
has to turn the ball over and what three
or four games like he's definitely
should be considered for that because he
is really taking control of that Indiana
Pacers team not brozo baller he's a
baller hey before we get up out of here
that's it that's it guys that's it but
before we get up out of here
who do you guys think won that trade the
Kings
or the Pacers that's a great question
the kings are playing good they're
playing good
the Pacers are also playing decent Holly
Burton's Ballin who won that trade
I don't know I think you got to just see
what happens right this this early run
by the Kings is really interesting I
love the light the beam I think that's
so fun uh the Kings haven't been
relevant for a long time I don't even
know how long it's been since they've
won a playoff season series or made it
but for I I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
the Pacers because they have a lot of
good young talent and you know you have
it locked up with Halliburton who seems
like a guy you can build around I'm
gonna say that I'm gonna say the Kings
so that I just like they're playing well
now and also if you guys saw me giggling
before it was because Gucci dropped a
comment and said how do you guys feel
about uh Sacramento Kings to win it all
I don't to win it all that's why I
laughed
flip Dallas flip dollar 23 says the
king's Gucci said the king's mj777 said
it's too early to see uh Chef boy RT
says I say it's even but if I had to
pick it'll probably be the Pacers
that's a good question that is a real
good question both of the teams are they
seem like they're balling with the uh
with the results after the trade uh
early on in this season there seems like
they're both getting off to some decent
starts so uh let's let's read let's
revisit this later in the season guys we
will talk about it as it as it
formulates and as the season goes on
um but it's been fun it's it's been fun
we we've done a parlay
we've also talked Futures Max the
producer wants to talk grading
people's bets but I'm I'm gonna say no
Max no we're not grading best today
we're getting up out of here because
it's time to win some money it's time to
go into money it's time to get these
people to go bet on FanDuel and ride
with us uh so we're we're I'm gonna sign
out I'm gonna say one last thing one
last thing
hip dog 522 just hopped in he asked Are
You Gonna post the parlay on Insta shout
out to the weatherman Michael Ritter and
Bryson we will absolutely post this
everywhere and when we cash we're gonna
post it again so you'll be able to see
it in just a few minutes let's go
hey uh I got my lucky t-shirt on guys
light of the world lucky t-shirt on
today so we're gonna get rich hey my
name is Greg Ivory next to me is the man
I like to call MB Michael Bolin and next
to him is the man that connects us to
you producer Ryan uh we're about to go
get rich we just put in the parlay
that's like plus 700 whatever whatever
it is I'm feeling good about it so uh
I'm out boys
peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]